that's operator standing or laptop
standing Jake we got to play operation
Parabellum the other day over at Ubisoft
it is the second season of content for
year 3 for Rainbow six siege it is also
the biggest update to the game since it
released there are a lot of changes to
break down but first I think we can jump
it into the operators because we got
hands-on with them
there are maestro and alibi you played a
lot of my stroke so can you tell me
about him yeah so maestro is one of two
defenders this season so unlike last
season where they start out with two
attackers now we have two defenders and
his thing is that he can place almost
indestructible cameras there are ways to
destroy it but you can place
indestructible cameras and have a little
window that when you hold when you hold
right click they open and then you can
shoot it you can shoot a pretty weak gun
but it's 2 inch drone on the wall it's
like a rapid-fire Twitter node and you
have 2 of those if you're if you're a
defender and say maestro dies and you're
still alive it'll become like a Valkyrie
cam so you can switch to it from the
other normal cameras and it'll still be
on the wall so yeah it's almost
indestructible but when they open their
shield to actually shoot the attackers
then they're like say a vulnerable and
you're also saying so this explosives
can get rid of it so if you put it on an
Instructables
an easy way to get rid of it I wouldn't
recommend doing that when you get your
hands on it don't put on destructible
walls but another way to deal with it is
dhoka bees phone call yak thing because
you'll get thrown off the camera so if
it is placed like in the hostage room or
whatever next to a bomb next to a bomb
and dou Covey calls then you're gonna
get thrown off you're gonna have to fix
that before you can get back on and then
also Thatcher's EMP sure deal with it as
well can put it on floors you look on
almost any surface that you could put
like say Yeager's abs on okay there
aren't in many situations like I was
telling you'd be funny if someone was
rappelling and then they looked down at
the floor and there's one right in their
face but like almost maybe 99% of time
you'd be
putting it on like a tile wall man you
can't do it right something something
worth pointing out with maestro though
is that he also has a LMG which I think
he's the first defensive operator yeah
it's like what 81 rounds anyone round
ready much don't have I been a cog which
was a mistake because it is all over the
place but I think it kill with it
there's other primary as the it's like a
double a 12 shotgun yeah so they both
have this I think they call like an ACS
12 or something like that and there's a
secondary weapon
I like their secondary weapons a lot -
there's one like mid range it's like a
357 revolver right and then the other
ones like a short range it looks like a
snub nosed shotgun pistol I know that
doesn't exist really but that gun was
really good for shredding walls I think
yeah yeah if you prefer using the LMG
then definitely take that his numb those
shotgun pistols you can basically clear
your way through and also glass haters
will be glad to know that the evil eye
can also see heat signatures through
smoke so yeah that's a good counter -
glad we finally have one I like glass
but if your glass throws smoke grenade
you're not completely defenseless
anymore alright and we talked about Mike
straws weapons let's move on to alibi I
played more alibi I really like alibi
again she's also a defender they did say
Leeroy a fan - Soph the game director
was there he said this is the last time
there will be two on one side so from
now on they'll be balanced there'll be
one attacker one defender for you know
the foreseeable future but L by she's
the first one people saw and they know
she can send out decoys so how that
works is it's a throwable object she's
got three just three of them yet so you
throw it on the ground and this like
metal bar will come up where her feet
will be and she'll be facing away from
where you throw it
it'll just be her standing with her
weapon the cool thing about it is if an
attacker sees that and shoots it they'll
be tagged almost like you see if jackal
traces someone's footprints you see that
red tag through the wall or just tag
someone a camera it'll look like that
but it'll be like alibis logo yeah one
interesting thing though we noticed was
that even if you shoot the the gadget
like if you know it is that hologram and
you shoot the gadget you still get
pinged oh really okay your beliefs that
happened to me I actually footage of
that - that we can't cut - so your best
option is an attacker is to recognize
that it's an decoy and not shoot it you
also said running through it too though
right yeah if you disrupt the field like
you'll know you disrupted because
you shoot it'll flash like blue like
hologram kind of Star Wars like if you
run through it it'll also like disrupt a
field it's pretty much a motion sensor
in her body almost and I like it a lot
it was cool like at one point I remember
in the new map which we'll get to right
away I threw down one of her decoys
behind a bar so they couldn't see her
base so like someone came in and they
could see her behind the bar and look to
them like it was just me I really liked
the idea of kind of messing with
people's like her whole character the
pilot based around her being
manipulative so she kind of controls the
information I really do also like her
weapons so she does have that other like
shotgun yeah the ACS 12:00 a.m. 12:00
time automatic shotgun but her
submachine gun I like somebody I like
the law I'm not mistaken MX for storm so
he played Ghost Recon Advanced
Warfighter
you might be recognized that I really
liked it it was a solid rimfire it was
like it was pretty accurate it wasn't
much of equal to it I got a bunch of
kills during our demo the other day it's
also worth noting that maestro is three
armored oh yeah one one speed and since
she's the opposite and also one thing
that I do when I mentioned with alibi is
that if you have alibi on your team and
someone exits the exits the the area
you're supposed to stay in building
yeah exits the building it doesn't give
away what yeah character so it'll still
say like defenders outside but it'll
have a question mark over so so it won't
immediately so and that's with your
entire team you can also mess with
people if you throw a decoy out of the
building it'll say the defender detects
outside so say they're about to push and
you throw one of those outside they'll
get that notification says defender
detect outside and like you said it
won't show like Yeager's spiderweb it'll
just show a question mark yeah like
buddy but it's only when you have her on
your team right so that's kind of
interesting I think that adds like a
cool little ability that might that will
probably come in handy best people
probably one think about so and then
outside of those two new characters they
also have one of your favorite
characters is buffed echo he is my
favorite operator in the game on either
side he now has two yoke eyes so
previously if you're yokai got destroyed
it's gone but now that gets destroyed
you can relocate if you're playing point
defense you can throw another one in
also a bunch of other characters got a
new piece of equipment a secondary
gadget but yeah so basically you can't
adjust angle of view that this camera is
fixed when you place it but it's
indestructible yeah
those were great for like on landings of
stairways or like if you could find a
long hallway that you could see all the
way to the end that's where I kept
putting it yeah and those that like
switches about between the normal
deployable shield barbed wire impact
grenades etcetera so just getting more
options to those characters as well and
again that factors into the whole kind
of this expansion being all about Intel
and manipulating it and I'm really
excited and then of course there are a
slew of other changes being introduced
with Parabellum as well villa it was
designed to be competitive as soon as
this season launches they're gonna put
it into the pro sport circuit who care
about that also one minor thing that
people will like if you want to practice
this map you don't have to do custom
games there's gonna be a specific
playlist for Villa and yeah yeah you can
jump right into it I believe that's
casual and ranked they said like four
weeks yet over four weeks four weeks and
then it'll be into the rotation with all
of our favorite maps it's fantastic I
like it a lot on it's a lot of like
different sight lines the hallways the
there's a cellar you can enter through
it's pretty cool to breach in at the
cellar and you go through what tasks
yeah you play as or I was playing a
sledge and I just like chopped it down
it's pretty satisfying there's like
three stairways up from the bottom so
there's it's a lot of verticality they
said they're from Sam verticality for
this map we found that there was a good
mix of like short and long sight lines
just a really good looking map which
yeah it's gorgeous much yeah
but then there's also clubhouse which
has a matte buff is what they're calling
it which is almost feels like a
redesigned to me it feels like a
different because so there's those two
separate areas on the second floor those
are now connected through like a
construction room and then downstairs
the the billiards room and the bar are
now separated before there was kind of
like stairs you could walk up to the the
next area but now there is a wall in
between and there's other minor tweaks
but I think those are the two that
really stood out to me but yeah overall
Clubhouse it felt like pretty much a new
map yeah - yeah it was like if you're up
top and you're trying to breach into one
of those points up top you're not pretty
much exposed if you're on the outside
there's the pick and ban system being
introduced it works differently because
like so we played a one-round of it
right or a couple rounds like two games
of it yeah you picked the first team
we'll pick an attacker and a defender to
ban and that will not only benefit or
the other team it'll ban it for your
team as well so I'd say we automatically
right away
like let's get kuvira the [ __ ] out of
this match yeah we could not use her at
all or lion and then attack her attack
wise we're like let's get lion out at
which a lot of people are like they're
gonna ban him all the time but again we
couldn't use lion either and then they
banned like glass that was really cool
because it also right after you do the
pick and ban it'll show what five
operators you're using in that round and
then one person gets the chance to
switch so in each team each round yeah
each round so each round you go and say
there's like a there's a lesion there's
a smoke there's a you know like you have
all five people lined up the fifth
person could say hey I'm gonna switch
from smoke over to frost and then they
wouldn't know that there's a frost of
course if you're drowning and you're
droning well you're gonna see her that
definitely shook up the game as far as
like Intel everything defenders had a
lot more Intel Anu is attacking
attackers knew who they were going up
against in defense outside of just
droning I like that it's more about like
the mind games which I think that's what
we're like that's what they're kind of
going for with this update whereas last
something it's all about those global
abilities Fink is healing her nano boost
and then lions drone this is more about
information and manipulating it and I
really like how that fits into the game
and so that is our hands-on time with
Operation para bellum that's about as
concise as we can make it there's a lot
to take in again and does Ubisoft
biggest update to the game as it
continues to surpass like 30 million
players if you're watching this then
they had those pro league games on May
20th Sunday where you could have seen
you know the trailers and the gameplay
trailers fear maestro an alibi showing
off and we'll probably have more in the
coming weeks from Rainbow six siege
thanks for watching
[Music]
you
[Music]